l'heure est grave les amis toutes les
filles d animer nous font rêver non
j'suis pas puceau ont été censurés
censure est donc quoi vais-je me
touchait chaque source
nous devons les libérer nous avions beau
stand by step c'est quoi c'est un jeu
dans lequel on va libérer toutes ces
pauvres filles censuré mais papa n'est
pas d'accord et papa mais si nous en
empêcher et nous devons être discret
games jour un d'accord donc on y passe
des jours quand même donc je pense qu'on
peut peut-être changer d'onglet juste ok
donc on en voit plein de trucs pour
libéré et y'a papa qui peut arriver de
plusieurs endroits et je pense qu'il
faut oui je photoshop ce poisson papous
ok c'est bon adata l'on va se faire à
terme qui met la pression fils de [ __ ]
avec ses super nes et super look
illustration pourquoi j'irais pas sur
belon tapis animée oui j'ai fini
pression choïgou mon travail et je suis
graphiste ans et ça va aller à tanger en
train de willow grenier mais baa
mais ça va pas
au jard le courant d'air qui vous l'a
grillé mec c'est trop stressant s'amuser
non mais ça va ça va [ __ ] de chair de
merde j'ai voulu un chat de façon qu un
bruit il ya un bruit que je connais pas
une chance de couinements c'était en
vrai c'était qui n'a pas empêché les
belles années fils nus et c'est fini
[Musique]
c'est la folie on a libéré samantha les
amis le devoir nous appelle
il pourrait y avoir sakura là dedans ou
peut-être même ses 18 hockey en continu
jour 2 [ __ ] c'est génial on est le
héros de l'animation japonaise mais qui
c'est incroyable j'ai failli à le
placard non mais mon père rappelle dans
le panier moyen terme dans le pas car il
ya un conduit qui ont eu ou pas car la
cuisine c'est ça qui est un petit copain
les trois j'envoie des saints pour
libérer des films importe quoi on
libérera véronique on est bon on est bon
mais bon allez à [ __ ] il enchaîné
medef défend
papa tu veux pas juste travailler et
gagner ta vie ou versa
au japon ils ont commencé oui on les
libère telle la reine des neiges grâce à
vous pourrez télécharger librement ses
illustrations bien évidemment jour trois
papas et plus psychopathe que jamais il
ne dort plus ne travaille plus il de
prologue
olalala télé mec tu vas au téléphone
faut que l'épaule gauche le pape a ainsi
requis dans le placard ça
cela jette adopté mec ça devient d'une
difficulté à puce oui j'écris en bois jk
rowling a commencé comme ça elle sauvait
des mecs d animer et à côté les grecs
auteurs c'est alors qu'harry potter
arrive à devant le château
allez papa tu peux pas test mon skill
willow resta au plus tôt on a fait pas
mal à plusieurs en plus franchement je
suis sûr si je fais un tweet dessiner
une fille très jolie d'animer cette doxa
aulas l'america trois éléments donc une
fois il ya plus en plus de cacher ses
impressionnants jeux red boys et ils
sortent de plus en plus il par contre ça
c'est vrai tu t'es fait choper il est
l'heure de parler
papa c'est pas parce que tu as du mal
avec les femmes qu'il faut m'empêcher de
les délivrer elles sont dans une prison
de couleurs tu comprends continuer je
peux pas continuer what saharien
sauvegarder mais grâce à un sketch
n'était pas jour un quoi
ouah
oh oh oh oh oh oh la faute cette vidéo
si on bat stage vous aurez plus qu elle
ne sais pas j'espère sera plus calme je
te paye nos canaux tout je voulais vous
montrer ses jeux trop bizarre mais qu'il
faisait ça me fait marrer à chez moi que
je cherche des gens indépendants sur
steam dans la catégorie indépendant ou
petit jeu j'en vois plein défilé des
voix c'est des simulateurs de rencontre
y en a un c'est toujours au solitaire et
si tu gagnes la fille est de moins en
moins vêtues et c'est que du dessin non
car un de méchant là-dedans mais je
trouve ça super bizarre et un peu mal
savane quitte à passer des heures devant
ton pc autant jouer à un vrai jeu et
puis qu'est ce tu voir des filles
d'animer tu tapes fixes et animées girl
voilà aujourd'hui n'a fait la sociologie
on a étudié ce phénomène qui est animé
girl sous forme de jeu vidéo c'était
palpitant
je comprend deux buts j'aurais dû 8 à
l'état de projet d'inversion a regardé
par tmz joe the world s
[Musique]